[Music]
overworked finding work life balance
achieving growth and progress in a lot
of areas executive dysfunction
struggling to make time for the gym it's
all making it difficult to sympathize
with my fiance about her not completing
tasks are you a veteran uh yeah
[Music]
yeah woo what's up this is John with Dr
John alone
show probably the greatest mental health
and marriage and parenting show ever
probably is that good no no probably
about it definitely it's 100 definitely
definitely definitely um and where we
may not be the best we're definitely the
best when it comes to Fashion Kelly's
rocking denim on denim which I highly
support I'm not denim on denim oh you're
not no I can just see the denim top I
just assumed you're wearing jeans I am
jeans but they're like hot are you
wearing denim on
sweatpants denim on Daisy
D that would be awesome no and um I look
like I'm trying out for sound garden um
I don't whatever hey we're so glad that
you're here if you want to be on this
show go to john.com
askas or give me a buzz at 1844 693
3291 and the new questions for humans
decks are out Thanksgiving Christmas and
New Year's grandparents and kids along
with all the others but couples parents
all of it all of it and we're gonna save
your holiday season and um so many of
you picked them up last year um and we
heard so much great feedback like oh
thank God we had these cards when my
grandparents finally put uh turn the
news down from as loud as it would go
and my parents put their phones down and
we were all staring at each other
somebody would pull these out of their
purse out of their pocket and ah so we
got a Thanksgiving question let's do it
we do all right defend your answer
quickly kissing after eating is a
romantic and nice or B gross brush your
teeth before you come that close to my
face oh gosh okay so I've got some
trauma around this question and I'm
saying trauma jokingly there was
somebody that I was just head over heels
for back in high school and we were
driving home from a date and I it's just
you know it's kind of in the air you
kind of know this is going to
happen and she looked over and she could
feel it too and she
goes hey I know that we should like kiss
but like like what if you have like
stuff in your teeth and I was like I
what and it's like I like like food and
stuff like we just
ate it had never occurred to me ever
that had never occurred to me I was just
18 or 17 just going kiss kiss kiss and
then I was like well I guess that's kind
of
gross and from every day since then I've
just thought oh we just ate that's I
guess I guess we could exchange food
particles that we just like that one
conversation is just stuck in my
freaking head so I would say this if the
if we have dinner and you go eat or
whatever and you can get swept up in a
moment and you don't even think about it
I think that's that's awesome and I
wouldn't retroactively be like oh gosh I
wonder if I got some her salad right but
if I'm like objective about it it
probably better if everybody brushed
their teeth what do you think I agree at
the very least you know couple good
drinks of water and a mint at the very
least especially like coffee I'm real
weird about coffee breath coffee breath
makes me want uh like my eyebrows start
to fall out yeah so as soon as I drink
coffee I have a mint or something if I'm
at work um but definitely I'm like you
I've not thought about it like in a
moment or anything like that but if I
think about it
um like sitting here now the idea of
kissing somebody with food in their
teeth or something is well and like the
joke on me that I found out was a joke
without me knowing it for years and
years was how totally clueless I am
always always not that that's a huge
shock to you yeah I'm waiting on the the
big reveal here well I felt the tension
in that car and I interpreted that
tension as like oh yeah and she was
interpreting the tension of like I saw
you eat a burger and that's disgusting
right so I was like oh I misread that
one um Jenna what do you think please
brush your teeth or like Kelly said at
the very least have a mint like that's
just okay so you're on a date and then
like it is a great date you have great
conversation and he leans over and
you're like I don't know I think maybe
it just depends on what he eats like if
we're like if it's like onions and
garlic like please I do not not want
that we're the most unromantic group but
if I'm going on a date I'm going to have
some mints in my bag so that just in
case just in case just in case have mens
in your bag yeah
yeah Nate you don't care do
you uh so I think that kissing in of a
self is gross either way there's already
so much
bacteria so much stuff going
on what's food at this point like it's
either
[Laughter]
way oh not romantic romantic we are the
least romantic Show on in any podcast
man have but let us help you with your
relationship let us help you kissing's
disgusting kissing one my favorite
things in the
world I don't know now you've grossed me
out too Nate you're probably
right fun runner. org.net let's go to
Mount Olive New Jersey and talk to
Jessica what's up
Jessica hi um thanks for taking my call
you bet thanks for listening to that
ridiculous discussion that's okay um I
had a a question about U my husband
thinks I'm
boring um I stay home I stay home and I
take care of our three kids we have two
in school one at home with me is five
and uh three and I'm not really sure how
to go about
is uh telling me I'm
boring most of the time somebody says
the word
boring it's about a particular thing
what is he complaining about are you
boring ises he calling you boring in the
bedroom is he calling you boring like we
never do anything around here or you're
busy making sure your children are fed
and watered and bathed and he just wants
to hang out watch t like what is he
saying you're boring about just that I
don't do anything I don't have fun or
anything like
that is he
right um I guess in a sense yes um I
don't I make sure like our kids are
taken care of and um you know a that
sense and then like I guess he's
left uh I guess on the back burner a
little
bit so is it a matter of truly there are
things to do with your
kids um or or is it they a good way to
distract yourself from having to be
around
him I
mean I don't think so I mean I love him
I like that we get to hang out and spend
time together and let me ask this way
watch is it awesome when your kids are
gone um no I love when my kids are
around and I like when I like when they
go to bed and we can have like our own
time and do our own
thing but he thinks that that's
boring um yeah I guess in a sense
yes I need some more details I feel like
you're being kind of vague so let me let
me say this two things one
um when I would come home and I didn't
know I didn't know what to do I didn't I
clearly wasn't good at being a dad of of
a of a newborn and I had never been
married to somebody who was the parent
of a newborn all of it was new and I
felt like I just kept screwing
up and so I just started working a
little bit more and a little bit more
and a little bit more and take it on a
little bit more because I was good at
that and sometimes somebody who's been
married for what you all been 10 years
in now uh we're together 10 married
three okay 10 married three and you've
got a eight-year-old and a what eight
five and three okay
um that y'all have not sat down and said
hey we've never been married and had
three kids before yeah and so
everything's new what does our sex life
look like what does like SP spontaneity
look like what does getting a babysitter
and figuring out like once a week or
once a month or whatever what does it
look like um what does like like uh I
used to call it the uh I still call it
the erotic envelope system which is it's
me just being a ridiculous but I'm G to
have an envelope and I'm going to put
five things in it and you're going to
put five things in it and then once a
week or once a month we're going to draw
from it and whatever it says we either
are going to try it however crazy it is
or we're if it just doesn't look like
like possible we're GNA like talk about
it and laugh about it and kind of dig in
on like there's some things you can do
there yeah unless you your kids have
become a
way to avoid not like yall time right
the kids go to bed and you got half an
hour to hook up you got half an hour to
watch a show you got half an hour to
drink and like have a drink and scroll
Instagram and kind of be next to each
other that's not fun that's not intimacy
that's not
connection yeah and if that's what your
kids are for then I think there's a
larger conversation to be had which is
for some reason my body wants to avoid
my my new
husband
yeah where where are you I mean I don't
want I don't want to avoid him I want to
be able to have that like we have a very
good intimate life sure um but I don't
want to um I don't want to make him feel
like he's just on the back burner and
I'm just taking care of the kids and
solely just the kids and like don't uh
forget about his needs have does he feel
like he has purpose inside his own
home uh yeah I think
so so what does he mean by
fun um just I I guess just like doing
more things with him like either like
pulling out a board game or watching a
movie with him sometimes I just want to
I'm just so tired at the end of the day
I just want to go to bed sure so I I
think often when somebody says you're
boring it's about sex life or often
you're boring it's you're using your
kids as a drug to avoid intimacy that
doesn't sound like what's happening in
your house and intimacy I'm not just
talking about sex I'm talking about like
being around me laughing with me
throwing water at me like those the fun
just interaction
stuff yeah so it sounds to me like
there's a pictures and words issue here
where he's saying the word boring and he
has a very clear sense and it may
be he's saying you're boring because he
is feeling that sense of that less
aliveness he doesn't like who he's
becoming as a husband and a father of
three and what he's going to do is look
around and try to get other people to
prop him up my kids got to play sports
cuz that makes me feel alive my wife
needs to feel in the blank cuz that
makes me feel alive
and he begins to Outsource his
aliveness to y'all but what that means
is when he outsources it y'all got to
carry it that's heavy and that's not
yours to carry but that is yours to
discuss with him if that's what's going
on here that's scary that's a recipe for
danger because that's when somebody at
work texts him one night something
hilarious and he gets that little spark
back because he feels
alive okay that's when somebody at the
gym says oh my gosh I've seen you in
here the last three months you are
looking amazing and boom feels alive
right or you start you find something it
makes you feel alive whatever that
happens to be so if that's what's going
on um you'll need to have that
conversation I
think here's how i' would approach this
if I were you okay you could take this
take it or leave it I would go on a date
and I'd get a babysitter and it probably
is a pain in the butt for you to always
have to be the one that gets a
babysitter but I'd get one and I would I
would say hey we're GNA have some good
deep romantic intimate talks and he's
going to be like oh yeah and you can be
like not like that and I want you to ask
him very specifically hey let's be very
specific I'm really taking it to heart
that I don't want to be boring I want us
to have a fun life I want it to feel
like this I want it to feel like
laughter and fun and excitement when you
walk in the
door and also there's three kids in here
and I'm freaking exhausted so I want you
to be super clear like when you say I'm
boring be specific what does that
mean and I want you to challenge him to
be very specific not this vague sense of
I don't feel like we used to I don't we
used to have all this fun well used to
is over we got three kids our life is
different now we're a decade in our
marriage is different we can never go
back to what it was but we can make an
alive fun wild time but I need some very
specific things and then you get to
Circle back and say okay in order for
some of this to be
true here's what I
need okay I need some support I need you
to take bed times if you want to have
crazy sex night fine but you got to do
bedtime while I go recoup while I go
fill in the blank if you want to go just
spontaneously go to a concert cool on
those nights when you say hey so and
so's in town let's go I need you to also
text and I've already made arrangements
for a
babysitter right so what are some of
these things that you need to begin
to help him meet his needs and it works
in a loop right and it sounds
transactional but it's not yeah here's
the what I need so that I can show up
and help you with what you need and
you're going to show up with what I need
to help me see how it just works
together and it's awesome man and needs
will shift and change over time let me
ask you this
um do you want to like when he says it
do you think do you feel it in your
bones like I want that whatever you're
like I want to I want you to think I'm
fun like do you want that or is it
really annoying when he says it like no
I I want to be more fun and more
like
spontaneous uh that he wants but I feel
like I'm just on a a regular cycle Loop
yeah you are three kids in the house so
what does feeling alive look like for
you when do you feel
alive
um I'm not particularly sure anymore
because I'm just in that Loop of
just I guess when we go out and you know
we have a little fun we don't have to
worry about the kids and you know just
once in a while that kind of thing is
nice but it sounds like you go out to
Exhale not to not to
dance usually
and I I'm using dance metaphorically but
you go out to drop your shoulders and go
oh thank
God uh yes in a sense yeah that I know
the kids are taken care of I don't have
to worry about them I can actually relax
because of um I struggle with uh anxiety
a lot leave it like leaving my kids and
things like that so so here's here's my
challenge to
you we often think that the greatest
thing we can give our kids is to be
available to 247 365 for every need and
every second and every
everything I think the greatest gift we
can give our kids besides obviously food
water and shelter and presents
duh
is a peaceful
home yeah an alive lit up Mom and Dad
and that means you have to do the hard
work of asking yourself what makes me
come
alive away from these kids is it re
eating is it running is it video games
God help you is it what what is what
makes you alive and sometimes it's going
all the way back to when you were a
little girl saying like what are things
I used to just love to do I love taking
care of things I love gardening I love
cooking I love building things I want to
start a small business and your
immediate brain is going to be like nope
shut that down you got three little kids
let's let's at least go a
dream and what I think's going to happen
happen is if you started like I'm going
to give myself
permission what you're doing like the
old saying goes you're putting your
oxygen mask on
first in order for my family to be whole
and well mom's got to be whole and well
and that means mom has to begin to do
the things that make her feel alive I'm
getting up at 6:00 every morning and
going running which that means husband
you've got to get all the kids out of
bed you want a fun wife then you need
need an Al live wife you need a live
wife here's the things I need and that's
not going to be perfect you're have to
negotiate blah blah but it's probably
been a long time since you looked in the
mirror and said what do I want to do
what would be awesome other than just
curl up in bed and take a nap right yeah
what is but what's beneath the
nap what would be I mean I love I love
baking that's my favorite thing to do
awesome could you put on a calendar that
you're going to bake for somebody in
your life once a
week yeah my husband loves when I bake
anything well forget him I'm talking
about other
people um yeah like bring the joy of
baking back into your house turn the
music up too loud wear hilarious clothes
whatever whatever you do and put in your
budget we're gonna hey I'm going to bake
and I'm going to give it to our neighbor
I'm going to give it to this lady at our
church I'm going to give it to whoever
and I'm going to start doing these
things and I'm going to get the human
exchanges of hey I baked this for you
can I tell you something crazy that
happened um I don't know if I've talked
about on the show or not my neighbor um
I think he's about 75 he's got a big
tractor and I've got a long gravel
driveway and our properties are
separated by a like a ravine it's like a
100 foot Ravine down there with a creek
down at the bottom and then it goes back
up we had a bad bad rain and it washed
out my driveway there's big divots in it
it was hard to get my cars up and down
and normally I hire somebody to come out
it's super expensive and I saw him
working on his driveway and I said hey
man can I hire you to do my
driveway and he said yeah but I won't
take your money and I was like well I
don't I don't just ask people to do
stuff for free and he said well I'm your
neighbor and I was like man that now you
made it weird so he does my whole
driveway I come home and it's
perfect so I sent my kid over with an
envelope with some cash in it and I he
left it there and then he ran home next
time wash is out and he automatically my
neighbors over there doing my driveway
and he said and I said oh man I waved
him down and he looked at me and said
you will not bring any more money to my
house I said fine so my wife who is
loves baking loves her garden man um she
loves her garden so much she just spent
a year going to get her Master Gardener
certification just because just so she
can get good at it right yeah and
um she made him a loaf of souro bread
and she had canned some pickles from
some some things she had grown and she
had some eggs from our
chickens that man got down at he was
doing working on a project in his
backyard he got down and came over all
sweaty and he gave me a huge
hug
because he recognized we had my wife had
given him we had given him as a family
something that money can't buy which is
time which is thought right and so I
walked away feeling so good but more
important my kids were with me and my
kids walked 6 Ines taller on the way
home like yeah that's what's up we just
did something cool for our neighbor they
didn't do nothing but it was a
transaction and I felt
alive see what I'm
saying I would love for you to begin to
seek out in your home what are the
things that make me feel
alive and also be very specific with
your husband have the conversation when
you say boring honey what do you mean ex
exactly be very clear what is boring to
you and he may need to start focusing on
some things that make him feel
alive my wife doesn't play guitar a lot
I do my wife doesn't go hunting a lot I
do I don't Garden a lot she does I don't
write nearly as much as she does I'm not
near as good she like and so we do these
things that help us feel alive and then
we come together and that alive plus
this alive creates a fire that makes the
whole house feel warm and the whole
house feel full of laughter and so
boredom we try to chase that with disco
balls and like and let's go to a concert
let's spend a bunch of money sometimes
it's about doing the things that make us
feel alive and bringing that together
great great great question Jess give
that a shot holler back at me and we
will be right
[Music]
back this episode is sponsored by better
heal hey folks delone here sometimes we
know what's good for us but it feels
like we just can't make ourselves do it
like our brain's getting in its own way
and that happens to me a lot and I'm
pretty sure it happens to you I know I
should play play a game with my kids
instead of practicing my guitar all
night but sometimes my brain tells me
that hey maybe that metal band's going
to call after all you got to get your
practice in therapy helps me figure out
what's holding me back from doing what I
know I should do and it can help you too
so your brain can begin to work with you
not against you sometimes it's just as
simple as talking things through and
learning how to intentionally Place
guard rails between yourself and
negative behaviors we call them
boundaries so if you're thinking of
starting therapy give betterhelp a try
betterhelp is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist you can switch
therapist at any time for no extra
charge make your brain your friend with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com dealone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com all right hey during the break
um we hooked that last caller up with a
bunch of questions for humans that way
they can chitchat
talk fall in love let's go out to San
Antonio Tas and talk to Salem Witch
Trials what's up
Salem how's it going can you hear me
yeah we're balling dude what's up it's
awesome to talk to you you too man got
got a little bit of nerves about it I
don't do this sort of thing often but I
have my reasons that I need to call many
of the other shows like the Ken Coleman
show on Entre leadership and and so I
think this is important I started with
this one here the groundwork to be well
enough to do those other things I want
to do in life I'm grateful man what's
up uh I didn't frame it as a question
but I'll go and just go back to what I
submitted and start there read that off
to you really quickly can't and I don't
see the original question so I'll be
hearing it new brought it up so I can
read it to
you so I've said overwhelmed with being
overworked finding work life balance
achieving growth and progress in a lot
of areas executive function struggling
to make time for the gym uh relational
connection and growth effective
parenting finding Community solving
other deficits uh it's all making it
difficult to sympathize with my fiance
about her not completing tasks and
carrying uh some more of the burden I
feel like I'm mostly
shouldering please advise so are you a
veteran uh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah oh man so I can Bann on a lot of it
um and and this I mean if there was room
for it could turn into a whole hour long
two hour long conversation but yeah yeah
yeah I try to be concise no I appreciate
that that's I heard it in your language
um
man are you still in um I'm a parttime
now part-timer
okay tell me about who you were before
you went in before I went
in uh initially
um I mean I
was I don't know I I a lot of time doing
a lot of things that I never planned on
doing that I never really had a passion
for and that's just been
the the kind of pattern for my life okay
there's been
um a whole lot
of disappointment when pursuing things
that I thought would would be greater
and bigger I tried to do uh Socom stuff
uh didn't didn't cut it out I didn't cut
it excuse me I didn't um didn't make it
wasn't good enough for a lot of things I
wanted to try to do uh I hate that it's
the theme um but I'm still doing what I
got to do in order to survive in order
to get by and and try and push towards
thriving rather than just making it I I
want to be doing things I have passion
for
and uh I've spent the better part of the
last year um taking in more wisdom and
knowledge and
adopting uh greater ideals and
philosophies and ideologies so on so
forth than I've ever spent any of my
time in my life before uh to try and
prepare to be this person this man that
I want to be and have the life I want to
lead
um so there's a lot of Failure to Launch
yeah yeah
yeah
um who in the world told you growing up
that you
suck me no you that that's the that's
that's absolutely the the the message
that's the tick or tape under your life
that's that's the voice you pipe into
your own head every day but you got that
from
somebody
who told you that if you would just you
got to go you need to do this or who
told you that I don't have uh I didn't
grow up with a lot of strong consistent
models to follow okay um home life chaos
was yeah I mean there was a lot of
moving around it was a single mom home
okay there you go that's hey that's all
I need to know that's all I where's Dad
where was Dad gone at
six
and do you believe me when I tell you
that there's a seven-year-old little boy
in there combing his hair with an
exhausted scattered mom trying to keep
everything together yeah quietly asking
himself what was so bad about me the dad
left what the hell was so bad with me
that dad didn't want to be
around I never really spent a lot of
time thinking about that I know you
haven't here's the deal think hold on
you spent a bunch of time and a bunch of
energy desperately looking for models to
fill to answer that
question and you chase it and you either
get it and you realize that your body
just moves the Finish Line it's not
enough or you chase it and you don't get
it and you go that's if I had a gotten
it that would have answered that
question I would have been enough
and here's my promise to
you from my guts
brother until you deal with that
seven-year-old little boy you will chase
you'll be amazing you'll start winning
things you'll make money you'll have a
good
job and your insides will be as Hollow
as the inside of a basketball you
yeah cuz you saw a soldier and you're
like that's that's that will make that
Dad of mine be proud even if he never
sees me there you
go and it breaks my heart to say this
because I have a 13-year old little boy
and I can't
imagine leaving
him but that call is not going to
come yeah well we've we've had our come
to Jesus moment it was uh when I was
becoming a father I decided it was
necessary to uh forg I spent a lot of
time throughout my teens in church uh
praying to God that I forgave him and uh
I I realized I think four or five years
ago I think four yeah about four years
ago um that I never told him that I
forgave him and I think so I initiated
who whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa homie what do you have to forgive
your dad
for
I think I needed to do it for myself
what did you have to forgive him for he
left
you you're old that no no no no no no
no you a
kid you're a
kid I asking for forgiveness I was
forgiving him is what I mean to
communicate okay all right okay you were
you weren't going to carry his crap
anymore no I was I it was for my
own freedom from that there you go okay
all right all right I got you all right
all right I didn't want to make it all
about this but I because we've had our
we've had our conversation we don't stay
in good consistent contact now but I put
my mom on the phone and I I let her to
because she had to deal with my crap by
herself and so I put him on the phone
and this isn't where I wanted to head
with I know I know
know but yeah I've I have released him
from that for my own sake okay okay you
you've let him go and
and you haven't dealt with
Salem right so you've done that work the
external work you let him go I'm not
carrying your bricks anymore you left me
you missed out on me and I hate that for
you because I'm a pretty good
guy and I'm a good man who serves I'm a
good man who strives I'm a good man who
works really hard on behalf of my
community and my country and my family
and you missed out on me I'm not
carrying that
anymore and here's the thing trauma's
twofold my brother and I know that word
gets beat to death especially in in the
uh military community and so I don't
want to just sound like another yappy
woooo
guy but trauma's the thing that happened
to you Dad left
right and trauma's also the thing that
should have happened that
didn't so you've dealt with the thing
that did happen
dad bailed
gone what I don't think you've dealt
with is turning to take a knee and
holding seven-year-old Salem in your his
face in both of your
hands and looking at him and saying I'm
so sorry what you went through
man I'll tell you my first step of my
freedom was writing my 9-year-old self a
letter dear nine-year-old John is how I
started it I'm so
sorry and dude I sat in my basement with
a spiral notebook and a pen and I wept
all by
myself because I didn't realize there
was a kid in there still asking himself
what did I do that was so
bad and here's the thing if you solve
that and I don't mean solve in a
mechanic militaristic kind of
way if you you look in the mirror and
say I love that guy I love
me and you don't make your life about
yep I didn't make this I didn't make the
comms team I didn't make special units
team I didn't make any of these other
things it's just another another notch
of failure I couldn't even keep my dad
around much less make this team make
that team now my fiance isn't getting on
board I'm not even doing I'm not even
doing romance
right instead of that that being the mod
the pair of glasses the model with which
you look at the
world you take those glasses on and put
on another set of glasses which are dude
I've been to Hell in
back and I'm still
here and I tried to fill it up with this
I tried to fill it up with that I tried
to fill it up with that bro there's
nothing to fill up
anymore and now you start looking at
personal development and looking at new
models and new theories and new ways of
doing the world and new ideas for
careers and jobs not to try to not feel
so crappy about who you see in the
mirror but because I love that guy and
he's worthy of having a great job and a
great career and work he loves he's
worthy of sitting down with the woman he
wants to marry and be like hey man let's
build something new I didn't have a good
model you probably didn't either let's
figure out something beautiful we can do
together right see what I'm saying um
the I think the issue with that part is
how to uh speak speak my fiance's
language and uh do it in such a way that
it doesn't seem like an attack I feel
like what I'm I don't insult I don't
hurl uh abrasive words I think I'm just
kind of
generally CT in the way that I address
things and I I try to like I I want I
think my my primary issue right now is
that I work too many hours and it's not
your primary brother your primary issue
is you're running from you I don't have
time to it's not it doing these other
things going it's not it find Community
um the problem is you're running from
you and right now work is your
drug I I work this much in order to
survive and I want to not be working
this much I want to go back to school
okay I there are I want to launch this
business I've been you know doing the
ground workor for for the past year and
a half I I have these things I have the
rubric I have the the
goals
um why I need why do you want to do
these things why do you want to do them
um these are things about which I know I
have passion okay these are things
what's stopping you from going to get
it uh it's a it's a matter of timing and
planning the execution I can't like when
finances are involved I can't like right
now I I need to be working this much in
order to get by I'm trying to get out of
debt I'm trying I'm on baby step two you
know so it sounds like my body's
breaking down because I spent so much
time breaking it down it sounds like
you're trying to do everything all the
same
time yeah yeah and you're spread all
over the place you're trying trying to
get you're trying to get in shape you're
trying to start a business you're trying
to start a family you're trying to dig
out of a financial hole that you're in
you're trying to heal from childhood
stuff you're trying to do everything all
at the same time yeah um be a good dad I
think I think all the stuff that
um my son's mom right now all the things
I've done throughout my whole life I
never had any passion for and then I
like I chose as a 10-year-old once I
finally decided that I I didn't believe
my dad was going to come back um once I
stopped listening to the phone calls as
if it was true I that's when I decided I
wanted to be a father and a good father
and I've had that passion that was the
career goal that I never changed uh I've
gone through other there I wanted to be
a musician rock star I wanted to do all
sports training all these things
throughout my life but I've always
wanted to be a father and this one thing
that I finally get to do because I am a
father my ex-wife is gatekeeping um and
withhold
holding uh custody yeah and so uh just
violation of the parenting plan so this
there's all the stuff that I got to do I
have to do Court PR work but hold on
hold on underneath all that is your boy
kind of going through what you went
through a little
bit he's young he's young he's younger
than I was he's
um I don't think so okay because I do I
do my best to be present but like I know
but you're I I'm telling you man you got
to trust me on this that nine-year-old
little boy inside of you sees this whole
thing starting over
again and he starts to sound the
alarms and those alarms get loud and
they get exhausting you know that and I
know
that and then you seek to solve it and
you're listening to all the right
podcasts you're listening to all the
right you're reading all the right
books Watching All the Right YouTube
shows and it says do everything all at
the same
time if you were trying to get a
successful business off the ground
you're going to miss some workouts
period Alex Heros talks is the most
honest person out in the space about all
that if you're going to get yourself
completely out of debt so you can have a
a firm Financial
Foundation you're going to miss some
activities with your kids because you
got to do a lot of
work but right now you're trying to do
everything all at the same time all of
it I think the greatest gift you could
give yourself is to go sit with somebody
and I know you roll your eyes I've been
doing enough counselors deloney I'm
tired of all that I'm going to give you
three months to better help for free
here's what I want you to do I want you
to sit down with a list that you've
already made here's all the things I'm
trying to do right now at the same time
get out of debt start a business work 40
400 hours a week right be a good dad
deal with an ex-wife who won't let me be
a good dad deal with my fiance try to
learn a new way to talk to my fiance cuz
I'm Curt and exhausted and my body's
falling apart and by the way I keep
breaking down my body because I watch a
lot of videos on YouTube that say that's
the way to Pat strength and whatever and
I'm trying to read 50 books a week and
I'm
trying and I want you to ask for help
help me pull these
apart CU I need to do one or two of
these at the same time and that's it I'm
going to do them in order kind of like
paying your debts off man I'm just going
to pay this one
off and I'm going to go to the next one
I'm going to go to the next one when it
comes to your fiance being Curts okay
not everyone talks as much as I
do you my wife would love it if I was a
little more Kurt I assure you that's not
the problem the problem is saying hey
honey I'm just a man a few words I love
you how can I love you
today not how can I fix you not how can
I make sure you're standing on your diet
plan or your workout plan or how many
books have you read today that's that's
not it how can I love you
today and if you have to quote unquote
solve something fix something be about
solving that question how can I love you
today man if you could just help with
the dishes if you could just on it got
it and let that be enough but I'm
telling you right now brother none of
that will be
enough until you let that 9-year-old
little boy of you that seven-year-old
little version of Salem who's still
sitting there in his bedroom wondering
why did my dad leave you've dealt with
that good for you I'm proud of you
man but now you got to turn and face
you most of the time that starts with a
series of letters dear seven-year-old me
when you write that letter I want you to
close your eyes and Visually go back to
being seven sometimes you have to sit
down on the floor to get that visual
like so your your ey line is is low I
want you to write that letter I'm so
sorry this happened
man wasn't your fault dad was going
through whatever dad was going through
and he left us and you didn't deserve
that
man thank you for holding the fourth
down but I'm working on it now I got it
from here it's time for you to go play
and you may need to write a letter to
11-year-old you or 13-year-old you when
you started trying your first drinks and
they made everything a little bit better
or you smoke weed the first time or
whatever it is you've done to C to get
to where you are right
now write a letter to the you that
wanted so badly to get into this
military unit and you didn't get
in but that guy off the hook man he gave
it his best shot he did he worked
hard and slowly what you'll be doing is
making peace with you
man cuz this sounds crazy to you but
you're worth being loved man you're
worth not leaving you're not the sum
total of of the failures you have the
failures have built the foundation from
which you will do something
amazing you got to stop
running love for yourself isn't
somewhere else it's right
here hang on the line brother I'm going
to send you both own your past change
your future and building an unexist life
give me my gift to
you I got you man call
anytime please write those letters let
that boy go we'll be right
back if you've listened to my show any
amount of time you've definitely heard
me talk about Thorne Thorn is an
incredible supplement company that makes
what I think are the best supplements in
the game I've taken Thorn for years way
before I had a show as you've probably
heard from listening to other podcasts
or just walking through a local corner
store there are a million different
supplements all claiming you're the next
great thing for all sorts of ailments
almost all of those claims and products
are either lying not good products are
just a waste of your money Thorne is one
of the very few supplement companies
that make Pure Clean tested and backed
by science supplements no fluff no
gimmicks no nonsense Thorn is what I
take personally and it's what I give to
my kids and make no mistake supplements
of this quality cost more than the
nonsense you see in gas stations so I've
partnered with Thorne for an incredible
25% off discount for our delone show
listeners go to thorne.com
delone choose what you want add it to
your cart create an account and when you
check out 25% off will be knocked off of
the entire order and here's the best
part that discount sticks around for
Life go to thorne.com
thelet
uone check it
out all right let's go out to Dallas
Texas and talk to Katie what's up
Katie hey John how are you are you hey
Katie what's up man how are you well I
was going to tell you I was at smart uh
money in Dallas back in January and I
just wanted to tell you that your God
Bless Texas performance with George was
the most iconic and legendary thing I've
ever seen in my freaking life and my
husband who's not a native Texan did not
recognize me next to him at that point
at all um it was amazing and so thank
you for do you have and you'll know what
I mean do you have some Texas Def
Leopard girl in there somewhere oh my
gosh are you kidding me doesn't every
native Texas Kelly's smileing is nodd in
her head she's like oh yeah oh I think
only Texans can really understand that
the State pride and this culture we have
here is probably stupid but I but I'll
say when that opening Rift to Pour some
sugar on me I I saw some Aquanet fly out
of people's purses and they start
started making their hair real tall real
fast and all I was like
oh we're just a few verses of we're a
few verses of this song this room's
about to get all
unhinged well it was amazing so thank
you for that well you are a saint thank
you for letting me live my high school
Rockstar dreams for just a few minutes
all right so's absolutely well um so the
last call uh really touched my heart um
mostly because I feel the question I
have today is kind of related to that
but it's not for me it's for my spouse
um the question that I'd wrote down was
how can I help my husband see his lack
of gratitude and contentment and how
it's negatively impacting his life in
our
marriage and I feel like um when I sent
this in we had just gotten out of a a a
pretty heated discussion and I was
really upset at him for a bad attitude
that he had had around my family um for
no reason he said he was hungry but then
after we ate nothing improved and he
just basically had a bad attitude for
two hours and this has kind of been a
recurring thing and I just had enough
and I told him that I felt like he's not
grateful for a lot of things and how
it's never really um and nothing's ever
really good enough and some of the
excuses that he's given previous L um I
don't feel like they're valid I feel
like that's kind of the Band-Aid he's
put on them because some of the things
that he's given reasons for when things
have
changed his attitude doesn't change
towards it and what are some
excuses um so like one of the things was
is he's from out of state and um he says
that um you know once he got friends
down here things would get better well
he has friends now and hasn't gotten
better um that's just one example uh we
switched churches recently he had had
some issues where we were at and he
talked like whenever we switch churches
that would improve well we have and like
it still hasn't
improved and I told him I said you know
back home your best friend who lived
with you for several years and your
sister like your family they all said
that that you are prone to
depression and so I I don't think this
has to do with where you live I don't
think this has to do I don't think it
has to do with any of that I think it's
a deep down problem that you need to go
to counseling and try to get through
with because I do know there's some
childhood trauma
um his parents were present but I I know
that he was told he was an idiot a lot
and I try to do everything I can can I
be really tell him that that's not true
can I love you enough and be really
direct is that cool yes okay
I was literally thinking that exact
sentence in my
head yeah and and and what I'm gonna say
is GNA be hard okay and he's not on the
phone and that'd be hard with him if he
was on the phone but he's not I just got
you is that
cool
okay got a kid who's told he was an
idiot growing up you're an idiot you're
an idiot you're an idiot and that's
probably the tip of the iceberg right
[Music]
mm and if he's like my family my wife me
and my wife she knew some but I didn't
tell her
everything yeah we were married for 20
plus years before I told her yeah okay
and so far on this
call you've said he just gets mad for
nothing his excuses aren't valid he's an
idiot he's an idiot he's an
idiot and
so without even meaning to the same
Dynamic has been
recreated
mhm because he tells you I don't want to
go be with your family and you say why
which by the way is a is a question in
counseling that is a no
Noe and then he gives you some answer
and you say well that doesn't count and
his little 10-year-old body says you're
an
idiot then he tries to go and he hates
it and his body tries to shut him down
and then you say have a bad attitude he
says well I'm hungry you're an
idiot and I agree he's got to do his
work no question about
it but the whole cycle is starting over
do you see how that's happening in in an
effort for you to say I love you so
much I want you to see how much Beauty
and joy and good stuff is around us
right
now you're trying to force him to see
something that he may not be able to see
right now and what he's hearing is I'm
an idiot I'm an idiot I'm an idiot yet
again I'm not
enough and I don't even know if he's
hearing that cognitively but I can I can
guarantee you his nervous system is yeah
well and I've tried to be and like part
of what I told him like I felt like I
wasn't enough and well and that's that's
exactly right that's exactly right um
and I know that I can't um I'm sorry no
it's okay you're good you're good
I know that I can't fulfill him that's
not a spouse's job um but I do know that
I've always
been like trying to tell him I
appreciate him and like for mowing the
yard he I'll tell him hey thanks for
doing that the yard looks great and he
just rolls his eyes and says you don't
have to thank me for that that's my job
like he doesn't appreciate that I
appreciate him and I try to make sure
that I that as much as I can does he
does he doesn't have the skill set to
accept a
compliment yeah and I know that got that
VI because that's
me and there are times that's why I
called you no there are times in a
meeting Kelly sounds similar Kelly
Daniel will say no John you did
good and I'm so uncomfortable with
that and that's what I got to work on
right here's this so I guess my next
thing was like how do I support him cuz
he he said he would be willing to go
okay to counseling and he told me you
know I'm not want to give up on our
marriage and I'll do whatever yes I just
need to know how to support him so where
I don't make him feel even
subconsciously like he's an idiot I
don't want to do I want you to do
whatever you have to do for you to go
feel alive short to violate your
marriage
vows because right now he sees his wife
as frustrated and devastated and his
body is blaming him yet again
M and so the greatest gift you can give
him is to begin to stand
tall and you go work out if that's what
you want to
do you go hang out with your girlfriends
if that's what you want to do hey I want
to go see my mom and dad I just can't
all right great man we're gonna have a
blast and let me tell you my wife did
that three or four
times and then I came around to my kids
and my wife and my in-laws are making
memories and I'm not a part of am not in
any of these
photos I have to
change I've got to change because I want
to be a part of their
life and it was seeing
light I saw their Radiance I saw their
light I saw these photos I saw my kids
burst into the door talking about how
great my mother-in-law is and great my
father and all of this and they are
amazing and I had missed it cuz I was
exhausted I was tired and so what did I
have to do I had to change the way I was
doing my life but I could only do that
not when somebody was shining a
spotlight in my eyes saying look look
how bright it
is it's when I saw it in the distance
and I saw my kids waving candles around
that I thought oh I want part of
that and it's when my wife started
saying I can't make you
better but I've got to be whole and she
went to
counseling and she started her programs
and she got a awesome group of friends
and she started writing a new book and
the whole house lit up and I wanted to
be a part of
that yeah does that make sense it does
and I have been going to counseling good
um and I think it just I don't know our
our personalities are so different and I
don't care about that that makes that
makes everything more fun good ways
makes everything more fun in good ways I
agree and it just like I've noticed
anytime we're doing something that's
like fun or out of the normal like we
got to go on an impromptu trip recently
and he he's he was so happy and so alive
and it's like when we come back to
reality right and there's not a
distraction
anymore he goes back into his little
cave and I don't think it's a matter of
there's not a distraction
anymore I think he goes back to a place
where his body says well we're back to
back to your fa your chamber welcome
home and you have to distract from
that yeah because it'll kill you if you
don't that's when I I've talked about on
the show that's when that's when years
ago I stopped asking people hey why are
you drinking so much to my God man what
happened that that's the best way your
body's figured out how to get through a
day yeah right and so it's less about
well there he we back now he there goes
fun husband and now he's back to we just
hiding out no dude what is in this
home what's in this home that his body
goes dude I got to get out of here but I
can't because I want to be a good
husband and a good dad so I just
disappear at my own kitchen
table I think that begins with
not um hey what do you want to do today
hey we're going to do this we're going
to do this don't forget this weekend
I think it starts as simply as every day
hey how can I love you today and honey
you at least owe me one
thing not done that and he just like
rolls his eyes and okay then you grab
his face in both of your hands and so
you don't get to roll your eyes on that
question let him know you're
serious and I bet you if you go quit
rolling your eyes and you go do
something else and you will head off
into the bathroom his body has won it's
avoided that that interaction because
that interaction is very uncomfort able
for
him but when you lean in close I bet
when you're serious and you get in close
I bet he locks in like a laser beam
doesn't he no I bet he does like I I
don't maybe I've not tried hard enough
and like may put my foot down and said
hey you can't cop out of this right um
but like I know I got the cards um for
humans for couples and he like just
checks out does not want to do it and
like he doesn't want to dig and I'm I
want to dig and and get to a root cause
of something and there's a possibility
he's a coward I don't think that's
it there's also a possibility that if he
opens that door hell's coming coming out
yeah I think so too because there is
some stuff he shared with me in the past
that it was hard for him to say but he
did say it and it broke my heart for Him
yeah um just some personal stuff that he
never told anybody yeah and the only
through that he's just afraid he should
be should be cuz he he experienced it
once he's already been on that road he
should be
terrified
yeah
and when you're walking through hell you
can have a bunch of people yelling at
you from behind go can't you
see or you can have somebody slide in
and put their hand in his side of inside
of his arm and grab his hand with the
other
hand and say I'm going to walk with
you but you at least got to show up and
you at least owe me how can I love you
today you owe me that okay I can start
there and here's how I would start the
whole thing honey I love you so
much and I keep pointing out to you all
the things that I want you to
see I'm
sorry I know you're caring a
lot
I'm going to go to counseling I'm going
to keep going I'm going to keep doing my
work I'm going to start this exercise
program I'm going to start a morning
breakfast with the kids I'm going to
start doing these
things it would mean the entire world to
me if you would join
me but I know everybody your whole life
has been trying to drag you along and
tell you the way you should be doing
things and tell you the way you should
be thinking about things and I'm not
going to do that anymore I love you too
much but you do owe me once a day how
can I love you and it would mean the
world to me if you ask me that same
thing
and basically what you're doing is
you're setting
down the bit that inside his mouth that
has been carrying him around and he's
not g to know what to do okay
whatever and then it's going to be week
one and then it's going to be week two
and then about week three I'm almost
willing to bet email me if I'm wrong
he's going to get enraged he's going to
get pissed
off cuz his body hasn't hasn't been with
somebody who isn't dragging him
around and he's going to have an anger
season before he works through what
actually
happened that sound
right yeah I'm not like why do you think
that somebody like that would even
partner with someone in the first place
um we marry our unfinished
business that makes
sense and my guess is that's the
question I've asked myself is like why
in the world are we why What attracted
you to me he loves you he is why he
loves
you he loves you more than life
itself and I know that because it's
exhausting for him to move about the
world and yet he tries to come towards
you as much as he can and then his
body's like we're
out yeah and you have probably spent
your
life trying to get somebody to see
something beautiful and
bright yeah my mom's always called me
her sunshine girl there you go that just
always been that way you probably were
Sunshine both because that was your how
you just came out into the world and
probably because that is the way your
body needed to operate in the system it
was born
into
yeah and so you're going to solve
somebody you're going to make sure they
see light everything is and he is going
to finally figure out why am I such an
idiot and y'all found each other and you
don't call him an idiot you love him too
much but you say that excuse is not
valid look how bright it is and he's and
you're shining a spotlight directly in
his eyes and he's like I can't see
anything and it just becomes a dance and
so you hear me say all the time on the
show just turn the lights on turn the
music off that's what we're doing here
that's you saying hey I'm putting the
spot light
down I can't show you beauty you have to
want to see it but I see it everywhere
and I'm going to go grab it I'm going
for
it and my God I hope you'll join me and
every day of my life I'm going to ask
you what what can I do today to love you
and I want you to ask me too you at
least owe me
[Music]
that unfortunately these challenges are
solved with
connection lean in we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up delone here listen you and
me and everybody else on the planet has
felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non- anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at John de
l.com all right as we wrap up today's
show we got a followup call follow-up
email from the Great and Powerful
merlanda I'm just seeing this for the
first time Kelly just handed it to me
the original call was February 27 of 23
so almost a year ago guess 10 months ago
nine months
ago all
right I talked to Dr John in February of
23 about how to learn to love my body
even though I was severely
overweight his advice that he gave me to
write down the negative things I thought
of myself and then to write down the
good lies versus truth plus advice to
seek out medical help led me personally
down the road to seeing my doctor and
eventually a bariatric
surgeon I had weight loss surgery and
I've lost
pounds
wow but so much more than than that so
in all caps I no longer identify as the
woman who called in February I love
myself
now I'm not perfect but I love myself
enough to treat my body and soul with
love and
respect thank you for helping me Dr John
meranda I'm G smile for the next
month I'm so proud of you for deciding
I'm worth
more gosh I'm going to get all choked up
man I'm proud of you
mandoa you have been down the road and
most importantly this isn't about weight
loss but 112 pounds that's
amazing but it's about you re falling in
love with that woman in the mirror and
saying man Merlin is worth laughter and
joy and fun and love and
respect
so proud of you everybody never forget
I'm just a knucklehead on a podcast
y'all are out there doing the work I'm
so proud of you we'll see you
soon